wie kann sein dass du so und männer
stimmen imitieren kannst fragt pad
minute
ich glaube meine stimme natürlich etwas
tiefer ist also als ich angefangen habe
mit den synchron damit den harry potter
geschichten aber auch viele gedacht ich
wäre irgendwie ein kleiner junge der das
spricht und dann 19 ganz überrascht dass
sie eigentlich eine erwachsene frau bin
getan um eine stimmlage ist einfach ein
bisschen tiefer ich mir angewöhnt so zu
sprechen und alle sind immer voll
überrascht jetzt frech mal normal das
ist meine stimme hinzu ich halt so heike
die meine frage wie findest du diese
tapete spaß mein richtige frage an mich
ist wie bist ok japanisch lampen
gekommen warum ich das frage weil es
einfach nur mega lustig ist immer liebt
in sachen mode fan von ihr ist
die kommen für mich sogar schon an die
harry potter 6 ran
na gut das war meine frage nicht hoffe
der bart wird ist mir die und japanisch
lampen sind entstanden weil ich ganz
viel mist lyrix gezeichnet habe aber
irgendwann kein bock mehr hat so darauf
und meinte ich wollte trotzdem einen
zeichen aspekt drin behalten und dann
sind wir auf die idee gekommen ja du
kannst ja irgendwelche animationen
machen an ihm jedoch was macht auch
einen trickfilm so ok wie machen wir das
dann habe ich mich mit dem kumpel
hingesetzt
wir haben stumpf irgendwas aufgenommen
und dann sind wir irgendwie auf das
thema anime gekommen und miteinander
herumgeblödelt hey leute wir sind die
japaner und ich habe mich sehr gewundert
dass sie tatsächlich das wort [ __ ]
angenommen haben beim wdr bei
einsfestival hat bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen
öffentlich-rechtlichen und ja so ist das
entstanden also aus reiner quatsch laune
und wann ich was zeichnen leute
panzerfaust
dies hat folgende frage die japaner
[ __ ] serie von kolberg ist meine
lieblings zeichenserie wie lange dauert
der schnitt und welche technischen
hilfsmittel benötigst du für die
produktion also japaner [ __ ] dauern
in der regel
eine produktion so eineinhalb wochen
wobei am anfang dass ich mir ein skript
überlegen und auch einfach mal so
spontan mikro an machen irgendwas
aufnehme und meistens lasse mich
inspirieren von pokémon oder sailor moon
oder guckt mir vorher irgendeine anime
folge an und denke das ist ein gutes
thema das verrate ich jetzt so sp sailor
moon verwandelt sich einfach so und
krieg plötzlich schleifen und plötzlich
hatte superkräfte so das habe ich dann
auch in eine folge eingebaut also ersten
skript überlegen dann aufnehmen dann
fange ich an zu zeichnen
das mache ich mit open kann war es
einfach nur ein standbild und das ganze
animiere ich dann in magix video deluxe
da kann man so einstellen ja hier bild
fang an bei sekunde 1 und wann darüber
zu sekunde 55 pixel nach rechts oder was
auch immer so und dann damit animiere
ich das dann und das hätte dann am ende
alles zusammen und dann entstehen die
abhandlung
und weil ich zu faul bin dauert das eine
woche eine frage muss natürlich konnten
wir bestellen also woher nimmst die
geilen ideen für den video
nein meine eigentliche frage lautet bist
du eigentlich so ein fernseh mensch weil
das fernsehen wie ich finde im gegensatz
zum internet immer uninteressanter und
dümmer wird
natürlich gibt es aber zur lichtblicke
wie die heute show oder die alten folgen
von switch reloaded und natürlich auch
keine sendung aber sonst finde ich hat
das fernsehen irgendwie seinen reiz
verloren was denkst du ich habe mir
geschworen ist jetzt zu machen
schenken ja da stimme ich dir voll und
ganz zu ich gucke auch sehr wenig
fernsehen wenn man das internet nicht
geht bei meinen eltern was oft ist dann
muss ich fernsehen gucken weil mir
langweilig ist oder krieg hat die ganze
scheiße mit und ich gucke dann meistens
tiersendung
also zusendung und sowas mag ich ganz
gerne unter dem max für männer männliche
männer und die männlich sind
ansonsten gucke ich gar nicht fernsehen
also man kriegt das immer so über
youtube mit was für scheiße bei im
fernsehen lief also ich finds auch total
schrecklich gerade dieser rtl
geschichten und sowas geht einfach nur
den bach herunter und es ist einfach
volksverdummung und die scheiße ist das
leute regelmäßig gucken das nervt mich
ja also nicht nur das es scheiße ist
sondern dass es auch geguckt wird dass
das schreckliche also ich stimme dir zu
ja es ist alles mist außer meines ändern
die video vettel schießt hat den wunsch
könntest du nicht mal ein richtiges
hörbuch aufnehmen und dann zum beispiel
bei itunes anbieten
er ist eine idee habe ich eigentlich
auch vor also hör bücher machen mache
ich ja jetzt auch also ich mag das auf
youtube hoch da die meine harry potter
geschichten
wenn ich die möglichkeit bekomme es war
mal so ein bisschen ins im gespräch weil
bei usm sind ja auch so mikrofone und
irgendwie ein stockwerk höher werden
tatsächlich hörbücher oder hörspiele
aufgenommen also wenn ich da mein fuß
rein setzen kann dann mache ich das
natürlich aber bis jetzt hat sich
einfach noch nichts ergeben aber es ist
ein bereich den ich gerne mal machen
würde